Je vais chercher dans le désert j'ai été
largué
mec tu as un nom je ne sais pas
je vais avoir besoin que tu viennes avec nous
je ne ferais pas ça si j'étais toi
ouais c'est le patron solitaire je veux cet homme
toi  me sont donnés maintenant j'ai besoin de savoir d'
où tu viens alors moi oui nous
revenons c'était quoi ces choses tu
me demandes ils ont mon fils ma femme j'ai
besoin de cette eau c'est la seule chose qui
compte qu'en est-il des autres personnes sont-
ils vivants ils ne resteront pas longtemps il
suffit de travailler ensemble
qui est-elle
facile je veux seulement savoir qui je suis tu sais
tu dois juste te rappeler qu'ils
reviendront avec plus et il y aura  pas de
survivants c'est ce qu'ils ont fait à mon
peuple
j'ai vu des hommes bons faire de mauvaises choses que des
hommes font de bonnes choses
vous pouvez récupérer nos gens
ils sont là
si nous intervenons on dirait qu'il va
bien couper là